What? Why are you DMing random married women in order to pretend
to be a teenager who's getting by a babysitter? That's freakish.
They've done weird role play
involving like teenage But even if we're not friends, that still
makes me sad.
It still makes me sad that he lied right to my face.
>> So if you guys missed it, Counter-Points had a stream
today and he was talking to Dubi and then I think that eventually
Destiny hops on. Dubi will make a point of, "Okay, well when
Destiny docks his people, he's putting people's family at risk
and he's like creating what we call a permission structure or
a a possible lens by which people will judge him and act against
him, right? That well we principally don't is sort of losing
his moral high ground to say people should defend me against
these these kinds of actions, right?" Well, they think THAT YOU
USE YOUR SEXUAL POWER AND CLOUT AND influence and money in order
to mentally
Give me one example.
Anna Faer. So oh so hold on. You think J Star, Creaman, eSports
Batman, they all hate you for delusional or non-serious reasons?
Yes.
Uh I Okay. That's crazy. >> Okay, dude. Because you are
reaping what you've sown. You are reaping what you've sown and
you haven't learned your lesson and it sucks. Okay, in my current
court case drama, who what is the what what is the sown part?
What did I sow here? Or was it immoral >> It was immoral
for you to have sex with Pixie. It was immoral for you to take
her homemade and send it to somebody that you'd only known for
10 days. Are you going to tell me how to run my personal life?
No, but if anybody was your friend, they would call you an idiot
to your face, which is what I'm doing right now. You are an idiot.
You are dumb. You ruin your own life. I see my friend who's a
up and I've tried to be nice about it and that's not working.
So I'm going to be mean about it. You don't know how to manage
your relationships. Anytime anybody challenges you on anything,
even if they love you, you run away because you're afraid of
growing up, but you are such a
THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE to be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell you that you're wrong.
It's impossible for you to take a L. The future.
The future of Counter-Points politics.
I think we're going to cover his opening monologue, what he'll
do for his opening monologue here. We'll cover that. And
uh from there I'm not totally sure where we go. So, I'm not I'm
not going to be slowly but surely burning all my bridges for
my uh you know, Snarkers
entertainment.
I just had a lot of frustration in regards to the way that Steven
was conducting himself. I I said it privately.
He threw his weight around on Friday. I resented him throwing
his weight around. I told him I wasn't going to comply unless
he had evidence of what he was alleging. He got upsetty spaghetti.
I got upsetty spaghetti. And then the next day uh he wanted to
talk again. And truth be told, I didn't think it was a good idea
for us to talk. We probably shouldn't have talked wanted to maintain
our friendship. We probably should have let it go. But I'm also
not going to back down if you're going to be throwing your weight
around. So, um I told him That's the funny thing is all of these
people are like, "Connor, why didn't you keep it private? Connor,
why didn't you keep it private?"
Connor didn't want to go on that stream. Connor said he was going
to sleep.
A bunch of people messaged Connor and said, "Oh, hey, Destiny's
like going to come into Melted Pot. We're going to all have this
conversation. Why don't you Why don't you come and talk to us?
Why don't you come talk to us, Connor? Come and talk to Destiny,
Connor." He wanted to go off. He wanted to go offline.
what had been bugging me for a really long time. It like You
got You guys understand like
I'm really not trying to be a [__]
it was a bitter pill for me to swallow. When uh what what was
it? So, Chud Logic and the Snarkers, the commentary
it was actually Queenman's fault. I'll blame Queenman right now.
Food Chops was a nobody. No Nobody knew who Food Chops was. Nobody
cared who Food Chops Food Chops was. She was probably getting
10 to 20 live viewers, you know, which is This is not true. Connor
way over plays this. Connor is just Connor is histrionic right
now. Especially when you're like I'm not trying to dog the streaming.
That's not what I'm talking [__] about. I'm not talking
[__] about the streaming. But then, what happened
was Queenman cut I'll be real. Queenman was a with 20 viewers
back here when he was talking to Food Chops, okay? What are we
talking
to 50 live viewers.
So, I was like, why even if we're lolcowing them, why are we
covering them sufficiently that you're creating a community
around her?
uh she basically says everything that she says, where she's like
a open defender of
I felt like Commentary and Chud were going soft on her because
they they thought that there was a uh an entertainment aspect
to keeping her around, which I also kind of found cruel. Like
like they're they're they're milking her while also providing
her a
And then, uh she took off for a year. And I was like, okay, that's
that's great, you know, like like I don't think we should have
an out and out con just as a part of Twitch and YouTube politics
and as a part of the community. And then, a year later, um maybe
year and a half later, she be He did go on like a whole crusade,
and I will say again, that is what we made
the Counter-Points
Valor Media seal of approval for was to point out that, "Hey,
Connor, you seem like a little You seem like a bit of a hypocrite
here. You were talking about how Food Chops uh people were bre-
like massively blowing up Food Chops and how that was wrong to
do, and now you're hanging out with Destiny who's massively blowing
up Food Chops cuz apparently a 60 IQ is the only person who will
step forward and spew the lies Destiny asked them asks them to
But, why is that the case? Why do we feel like that's the case?
Right? Why won't an intelligent and well-put-together, you know,
articulate person come out and defend Destiny?
There are zero people doing that, by the way. There are zero
people who are informed of the facts, intelligent, articulate,
and will come out and defend Destiny. Not so erudite says they're
friends or had said they were friends. There's a reason she will
not go anywhere near this guy in a professional sense right now,
right? Like she wants nothing to do with with this guy in a professional
sense. It's very obvious. He just continues to crash out. Mr.
Mouton and Dan do, but
honestly, I I don't understand why.
Or Dan. Dan's got like all this other stuff going on. I actually
don't get it. I really don't get it. With Dan. With with Mr.
Mouton, I don't think he's got a lot else going on, so >> becomes
like Destiny's strongest soldier after the debate. And then Oh,
also, I do think that for Dan and Mouton, they are not they like
just don't want to look into the facts. You know what I mean?
They Yeah, they just don't want to look at >> During the
summer, I'm like, "Hey, Destiny, my friend, my brother in Muhammad,
peace be upon him. Maybe like you shouldn't have
as your your primary litigant of your drama." And he's like,
"Nah. Nah." Okay. Well, what am I supposed to do with that? Because
if if I freak out and attack her, then I'm giving her more attention.
If I freak out and attack Steven, then I'm not I'm not going
to get the desire I want because he's always the double and triple
down kind of guy. So, if I go scorched earth over that topic,
he's going to triple down on it. So, maybe I can just back off
a little bit and gently push him in the background. But there
was no there was nowhere to Dude, there's By the way, they're
like
>> there's like a VC in that melting pot server last night.
I was listening to it off and on while I was in a VC with some
other people. And
like the Destiny defenders are just low IQ. They are just like
incredibly stupid
It's really sad.
Like there there is nobody intelligent who's on that side who
isn't just like motivated by something else. Like there there
could possibly be like some smart people who are like sort of
adjacent,
but they don't know the facts and they they kind of distance.
Like Like I'm telling you Hutch is like a world-beater IQ in
this universe right now. Hutch is like far more intelligent than
the average person there right now,
Okay, Arthur. I don't know in which direction you mean that,
but whatever. Um okay. So that that that was one of the things
I was stuck in my piece of popcorn stuck in my teeth. And then
the other piece of popcorn that was stuck in my teeth, I think
I told you guys this, but I'll tell you now in a more calm is
that uh Britt and actually her husband DM'd me first. I got I
got a mention on Twitter. I'm going to narrative this because
to my recollection this is exactly what
I got a DM or I got an @ on Twitter. "Hey, Destiny is ruining
my life and ruining my family, and no one will talk about it."
@ four creators who are Destiny's
uh orbiters. And so I'm not the kind of guy to, you know, basically
like ignore problems, you know? Maybe I'll minimize my problems,
maybe I'll attack my problems, maybe I'll criticize my problems,
but I'm not the kind of person to ignore my problems. So I I
like, "Okay, let's take this into the DMs." So we go into DMs.
And uh Devil
Devil basically tells me, and unfortunately this is on a suspended
account, but I guarantee you like somewhere in my uh pictures
I have uh the screenshots of the conversations that are relevant.
He basically says,
I'm married. I'm a political dissident, I guess if you don't
want to call him a graper,
Political dissident.
Okay. He basically says,
I'm married. I'm a political dissident, I guess if you don't
want to call him a graper,
and Destiny has been my wife for almost a year.
Uh they've done weird role-play
involving like teenage And by by the way, I don't want to exaggerate.
I I So so I'm not going to exaggerate. Based off of what I understand,
um it wasn't like a
diddling thing. It was like uh teenage babysitter role-play thing.
Okay?
But still, like it's weird, dude. You're You're 40.
You're 40. Like like get Why why are you DMing random married
women in order to pretend to be a teenager who's getting by a
babysitter? That's freak [__]
And then there's going to be some dead I Okay, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. We all We all knew about that. Is Is Connor saying
he he couldn't keep this, you
he couldn't keep this out of the limelight cuz it's the exact
same thing as the Rosie Embs?
That seems odd.
Weird. Okay. All right. All right. Very
there for a second because I think I'm going to pull this up
because I think it's important. Cuz I sent this message
basically knowing It looks like It looks like Destiny blocked
me, unblocked me, and then reblocked me.
Uh I'm just going to I'm just going to read I'm not reading his
side of the
I'm going to I'm going to read exactly what I said. I sent this,
so maybe I even found out about it earlier. I might have found
out about it in November cuz I sent this on November 22nd of
2025.
I said, "Dear Steven, I value our friendship and want to continue
it, but you are
A traditional Catholic man messaged me on Twitter saying that
you had sex with his wife as recently as February. He wants to
blow this up into drama, the
Dude, "Dear Steven."
>> Why did you write it like that? Just seems odd to me
right up right off rip, you know? Off rip, "Dear Steven."
The the value our and want to continue it, but you are
A traditional Catholic man messaged me on Twitter saying that
you had his wife as recently as February. He wants to blow this
up into drama. The wife wants it to stay quiet. His wife is actually
a fan of mine and contacted me as well saying she was on the
rocks with her husband and that she was the initiate initiator
and voluntary participant in the However, she also said that
you knew that she was married and a psychological mess and encouraged
her to stop messaging. That being said, you guys continued. She
mentioned that the messaging was  spicy and I inquired
as to what that spice was and found out you are of
Spicy, eh? It was spicy.
Very spicy. Okay. And then he looked into it. Not just that,
but you mentioned your ex-girlfriend, Liliana, found the messages
and was angry with both of you. Her fear was that Liliana may
have taken screenshots and may leak them out of revenge if this
all blows up. She was arguing with her husband and in an argument
admitted to the messages. The husband, as a traditional Catholic,
his honor is insulted and he wants to destroy you. To my knowledge,
he does not have copies of these messages. However, this brings
me to our friendship. Okay, so Connor is doing some background
investigating. He's talking to these people and they're concerned
that Destiny's ex, apparently,
would have screenshotted some messages so that she could share
them with people and to blow them up, I guess. I think you are
an intelligent, charismatic, funny,
Why would Why would any of this blow him
The only thing that would be getting leaked here is that he was
doing the exact same thing he was doing with Rose. So, why would
any of this have blown anything up? None of this makes any sense
whatsoever.
Like there is literally
that doesn't make any sense.
That people are like very concerned because Destiny wanted to
pretend he was a little boy getting babysat.
That is out in the open. That's been out in the open for a long
time. torically gifted man and I respect and admire you and your
talents. However, I think you're a self-destruct- destructive
who has to constantly test the loyalty of your friends. Conscious
or not, you engage in indefensible behavior and look to see who
sticks around. In my opinion, you walk the straight and narrow
and then get bored every few months, so you blow everything up
around to see who sticks around. It's a self-fulfilling
That's true. That's definitely true that like there's something
there going on. I mean, I think it's just the low empathy thing,
right? The low empathy like low self-control, low impulse control
thing.
Like he just he just
enjoys it? Like he's just very much enjoying going through the
emotions of this. I think he probably enjoys it as well with
all of these people being attached professionally. I know for
a fact I went on a rant like talking towards talking to Connor
and Not So Erudite on not directly, but of course just to myself
on a stream where I
Just understand that you've seen this pattern unfold that everybody
attached to Destiny has had their lives blown up by this guy
like being incapable of maintaining any sense of decorum, any
sense of like normal behavior. Like every single he will blow
it up again and you are basically using your reputations to bolster
his and he will blow you up for it. Like you will not get consideration
from him. He will not consider you when he takes risky like when
he makes risky decisions, right? He will blow you up. He does
not care, does not think about you guys. He has no concern for
you in his head whatsoever.
And I said this it's got to be in March or something of 2025.
And here it is again another example of Destiny taking one of
these risks doing one of these things.
Uh isn't this because it's post his oh, I'm better now that I'm
on Vyvanse arc? Oh, advanced basics. Welcome back to the Starking
team. I didn't even think about that. Yes. I I forgot. He no
longer Right. Oh, that's beautiful. I didn't even think about
that. That we're post-Vyvanse.
We're post like I don't engage in these risky behaviors anymore
because I'm on Vyvanse now. Oh my god, that is good. Yes.
Like I I knew this
because I didn't ever take the Vyvanse thing seriously. It's
just funny to have yet another lie that's so obvious,
Like to me, it just shows how bad his word is. Like how his word
is just worth
That's the That's the funny thing to me. You act in such a way
that any sane person concerned with your reputation would betray
you out of a sense of self-preservation. I sent that in November
22nd of 2025.
Tell me how that is not exactly
what has happened. You're milking this a bit too much, don't
you think?
If Connor were literally reporting Destiny to the FBI and announcing
that on stream, I know this man's a
which is not happening, by the way. I'm just using an example.
It It wouldn't matter to these people. They would still be in
here going, "Isn't it a little weird to like be that interested
in what he's doing with his Have you ever heard of like verbal
catharsis?
Are you like Are you like just really obsessed with this I'm
literally getting out what's in my
Yikes, why leak this This is like a really bad look for you.
This is like a really weird, bad look for you. You're like obsessed
with this
You're like And you're backstabbing him over this?
>> doesn't shock me. So no offense to Destiny Halcyon.
If If I say, "Hey, I got some [__] to say." And then
you go, "This isn't healthy. Don't say it." I'm going to get
pissed off. I'm going to get resentful. And I'm going to might
even time you out, bro. I'm not I'm not having Destiny sympathetic
people leaking private info is one of the reasons why Hush will
not collab with you going moving forward. Okay, [__]
him. Be a if you want.
Wait, what was that? might even time you out, bro.
I'm not having Destiny Oh, leaking private info is one reason
Hutch will likely not collab with you moving forward.
Christian Valaris, this I believe is a like was a mod in his
channel, was one of his main guys, wasn't it? Christian Valaris
people. Leaking private info is one of the reasons why Hutch
will not collab with you going moving forward. Okay, [__]
him. Be a if you want. Probably not helping you doing a live
stream. That's another thing. Done.
So, what would happen is there would be a secret.
There would be a secret.
You know, um in 2022,
Lauren would say, "Oh, yeah, Destiny and I aren't dating, but
we're really close friends and he's helping me through my divorce.
But don't tell
Don't tell anyone that I'm divorced. Don't tell anyone that I'm
that I'm close friends
with Steven.
Okay, now, like like I shouldn't have kept that to myself. I
shouldn't I shouldn't have told her, "You you need to go public."
Same thing with same thing with Destiny. Destiny would be like,
"Oh, you know, um you know, like like this situation with the
with the with the traditional Catholic man. I would find out
about that and I would say, "Hey, man, this is pretty [__]
And then he go, "I'm not I'm not keeping any more secrets. There's
no more
You tell me something that's [__] up and somebody
asks me about it, I'm telling them. I'm not I'm not sweeping
for your [__] up >> what? We're going to we're
going to turn this over. We're going to keep Connor in frame
as best we can, but we're going to get on to the chat here cuz
this is kind of important. Why why go public? Because it's destroying
their lives. That's why. The secrets are destroying their lives.
That's why. I don't have any secrets. You know why I don't have
any secrets? Because I conduct myself in public the way that
I conduct myself in private. The only sins that I have The only
sins of lying that I've ever done are sins of lies of omission.
Meaning somebody asked me a question that was inconvenient for
a friend of mine, so I pretended that I didn't know the answer
to the question. I said, "Oh, I don't know about that. I might
have to research that a little bit." Dude, people think, like
depending on what you're omitting, a lie of omission is really
bad, right?
It's It's Man,
it's tough.
I can't believe he just admitted that straight up though. That's
That's a little bit crazy. >> doing that anymore. It's
not happening. I'm not sweeping for anybody else's secrets. I'm
not keeping my own secrets. You ask me, I tell you. That's the
relationship. And by the way, if that's Hutch's problem, oh,
Connor leaked a bunch of [__] personal [__]
Okay, I don't trust Connor. Good. Don't trust me. Don't trust
me. Don't Don't Don't come up to me. Like let's say Hutch relapsed,
but he wanted to keep it a secret. Oh, hey Connor, we're internet
friends, right? I want you to know that I started doing heroin
again, but I you know, I I got it under control.
No. Somebody says, "Hey, uh Hutch has been a little bit loopy
recently. Is he on heroin?" I'm going to go, "Yeah. Yeah, he's
on Dude, uh holy Let me say Let me say to Oh my goodness,
Dude, they're going to blow They're going to be so mad about
that. They're going to be so angry about that.
No, no, no, he's joking. He's saying that if Hutch came to him
and said that, he would not lie about it. He's done lying by
omission. That if you ask him something, he's done lying by omission.
Let's see. Uh dude, Connor leaked a bunch of [__]
personal [__] Okay, I don't trust Connor. Good. Don't
trust me.
It's done.
It's done. Not doing it. Everyone lies. Don't No, I don't.
No, I don't. I act as though my actions on this plane of existence
are make me accountable to the creator of the universe, and when
I die, I'll be judged.
That could be
mythological. That That could be metaphorical. For all I know,
I'm dying and I'm going straight in the dirt. It'll be like mindless
oblivion. But I'm going to act as though I'm accountable to the
creator of the universe. And that involves not lying. So, I'm
not going to [__] lie. [__] yourself.
[__] yourself for even insinuating that everybody
routinely commits lies of commissions. You're a [__]
piece of [__]
Why did Officer Nasty's comment get deleted for saying Connors
always had this position for years? Why is that getting deleted?
You're over moderating.
You are over moderating.
What would your drill instructor say?
Wait, why?
Dude, dude, that's crazy. Officer Nasty says Connors had this
position for years, and then apparently gets deleted?
Bro, that's That's crazy, man. That's This is Oh, man, this is
rough. >> instructor would say >> watching this happen
to another person.
He would say, "Conduct yourself in an honorable way in public."
He would say, "Have the [__] bravery
to do what's right when you think it's right. Have the commitment
to stand by your principles." That's what my drill instructor
would say. What's a JJ did tie buckle? JJ did tie buckle. It's
like justice,
judgment, dependability, initiative,
tact, integrity.
I forget the other ones. Your leadership principles. Let me take
a look. You're leading support for Connor. It was That's like
Listen, my community wasn't like that because of how things broke
up, but I do think like eventually
I just noticed
there's like still people like this in my community who will
like defend stuff reflexively. Like
Oh, man.
Like defend defend Destiny stuff like reflexively before they
have any conversation on it. And I I get the feeling that Connor's
going to have to suffer through that for a while. Like it's just
like How do you talk about it other than in the framing of like
a cult or brainwashing?
Because it's like these people don't have a reason or any logic
to why they do what they do. They don't think about it. They
just do it. It's like reflexive for them. It's It's crazy to
watch and see just see it happen over and over and over again.
Let me Let me tell tell you what they would do.
My drill instructor would say, "Remember your leadership principles.
Justice.
Steven is conducting himself in an unjust way. Judgment. Being
able to discern what's happening in a situation. I'm using my
judgment. Dependability. I'm wildly dependable as long as you
don't want to make me carry your
Initiative. I'm always initiating. Decisiveness. I make decisions
and I stick by them. Tact. I have no tact.
I try to have integrity in so far as I am okay with what I am
and I am what I am. Enthusiasm. I am wildly enthusiastic about
my job. Bearing. I do have excellent bearing. Unselfishness.
I'm not very selfish. Courage. I try to do what's right regardless
of whether or not it's hard. Knowledge. I think I have decent
knowledge. Loyalty. I think I demonstrated that I have pretty
strong loyalty and from my perspective, I'm still being loyal
to Steven. He's my friend. He's [__] up. I'm not
going to I'm not going to stand by and be part of his self-destruction.
So, if he wants to end our friendship, then so be it. And endurance.
I have the endurance in order to endure
whiny-ass DGGers in my chat.
So, why does your Twitter account keep getting banned? Because
I keep using homophobic and ableist slurs. Cool. That's That's
nice. Connor's just taking personal responsibility there. Very
>> But no offense.
When you're being uh when you're being effeminate and weak and
you're not thinking
I'm going to call you homophobic and ableist slurs.
Connor, always liked you. It's too bad the friendship ended like
this, but life goes on. I think the reason I subscribed to you
initially was because every time I saw you on a debate panels,
you
I make the content. But if you come in here I don't know if I
believe that.
I'm I'm going to freak the [__] out on you, okay?
There's like this pattern that man, I should come up with a better
way of describing it. But essentially, what happens with Destiny
is a more evolved and stronger version of what happens with TeckTone.
Oh, sorry. Yeah, what happens with TeckTone. Like Destiny's just
better at it. This perpetual self-victimization that happens,
you slowly filter down to the most loyal people who are the most
exploitable, the most like like you just always paint yourself
as the victim over and over and over again, and you always will
find people, especially if you have a big a big platform, you
will always find people who are willing to help you and try to
pick you back up, and you have to do no work. It's like a method
to succeed while doing no work of your own.
You could just consistently paint yourself as the biggest victim
possible over and over and over again, and people who are like
it's the exact kind of person that would like prop up an addict
through some addictive behavior, right? That would keep helping
them even though they keep like keep descending, keep like um
you know, making massive mistakes in their life because of their
addiction,
but somebody just keeps, you know, coming in and holding them
up. Chibbi strat? Yeah, Chibbi and TeckTone are way, way, way
worse at it than Destiny is. Destiny is so much better at it
than anybody else.
and dude, I love this phrase so much. He He uses this phrase
so much. I don't want to paint myself as a victim, but
I I shouldn't be painted I hate I hate I hate being like acting
like a victim,
Dude, he uses this phrase so much.
It's crazy. Chill the [__] out. So, anyway, all all
suffice to say, I think Connor got taken advantage of here, and
I think that explains why the entire cult sort of comes and lines
up behind him, especially when they perceive him as persecuted
for some reason. Like everybody lines up behind him because right
now it's like the starkest he's painted all these villains. It's
a it ties into why he has to do villains only, why he doesn't
have like a
Maybe he did the Israel thing. Could the Israel thing have been
like a positive direction for his channel at some point? But
otherwise, it's all setting up villains that he needs to take
down that he's being like held down and persecuted
Every single time. Because again, he is the victim.
He's like the internet's biggest martyr. He If people would just
stop attacking him and and trying to hurt him for no reason,
then eventually
he'll save democracy.
But it's just every all of these bad actors are holding him down
and preventing him from being successful.
It's very
you start to see why it develops into this cult-like thing, right?
Like basically, if you are saying something negative about Destiny,
this is the mindset of all of them is essentially they think
democracy can be saved as long as people would stop treating
this guy unfairly. And so they attack, right? They attack attack
attack anybody who says something negative about him. Because
that is in itself, if you have a negative opinion of Destiny,
it's like evil. Uh Wick talked to Destiny for 5 minutes and came
in to an agreement, you could have done the same.
But Wick Wick literally
Wick literally changed his Discord policy and refused to enforce
his Discord policy, right? People in Destiny's community were
recording his
He refused to enforce that policy or and he changed the policy
because des- because what Destiny was asking, right? He didn't
kick Doobie, but he gave up like basically the privacy of his
Discorders. And that's why people were mad. in your chat but
you still you know, I would appreciate it if you moderated him
heavily. But you know, at least kick him out of the Discord because
I don't want him uh conducting gay ops in order to convert people
uh away, you know, into like haters of If he had come to me on
a personal level and said that [__] I probably would
have been like, "Okay."
Six years of relationship, you're uncomfortable with something,
you're expressing it like a man, you're making a direct ask.
You know, you're not trying to strong-arm me with your position.
I probably would have agreed to it. But that's not what he did.
He like Mouton came on while I was describing what I felt was
an implicit
And uh Mouton said, "Yep, that's the implicit threat. If you
don't get rid of these people, then we're we're going to [__]
we're we're not going to associate with it you anymore. You can
go [__] yourself."
And so We're taking our business elsewhere. >> result,
I was like, "Oh, okay. [__]
You want me to kick out Doobie? You want me to kick out Officer
Nasty? Show me evidence that they're doxxing, swatting, or harassing
Because talking [__]
about people on the internet is not a
I talk [__] about people on the internet. Destiny
talks [__] about people on the internet. Every creator
and every fan of this space talks [__] about people
on the internet.
if you want me to ban these people because they are your malicious
digital harassers who are engaged in a prolonged
digital terrorist campaign,
you need to show me evidence.
And when I asked him for evidence and I confronted him about
the fact that he doxxed two people without good cause, he freaked
the [__] out. And I I'm not I'm not going to do that
[__]
I'm not going to do that [__] And another thing,
another thing that I'll tell you that I'm uh Death Lily, I'm
sorry Connor, you chose to stream the conversation. You could
have done it to you privately. I already did.
Uh earlier.
Connor one
chose to chose to have the conversation in a place where multiple
people could have streamed it. I believe multiple people did
stream it, by the way. Destiny asked to talk to Connor in a place
he knew would be streamed. That was not on Connor.
I'm sorry. Stop blaming Connor. That is not on Connor. Destiny
asked to have that conversation in a streamable VC where multiple
people streamed it. You cannot say Connor streamed it, it's his
fault. Shut the up. In November, I I read a like for Saturday's
conversation
for Saturday's conversation, I did have a private conversation
with him. And he's the one making the ask. Why didn't he take
it privately?
He's the one who wanted to join the
I told him what I want or like I articulated what I wanted out
of the situation perfectly all day. Why didn't he take it to
DMs? Why is it my
when my friend of 6 years is implicitly threatening me, why is
it my job to take it to DMs? That's not my job. And he knew what
he was doing. He obviously knew what he was doing. Wait, is Connor
an anti-fan now? It's a well-trodden path. No.
I don't even see it here. Too bad. I'm not going to dedicate
the next 2 years of my content to hating Destiny. I don't care
that much.
I still like Destiny, you idiots.
I really I really wish that Destiny was a better person, but
he's not. And he's
And I'm not going to be a part of his
So, I'm not No. No, I don't hate Destiny.
Lord and I, we text every few months. We're We're We're not close
close, but we're friendly.
I am getting divorced.
I tell Lord about it. I tell Steven about it. And then I'm kind
of thinking like I'm going to be single. I don't want to be
But who who can I date? Because I actually I enjoy partnership.
I enjoy having a good friend. Right?
What was the lie? Don't worry, I'll tell you momentarily.
So, I actually go to Steven.
>> First,
I don't even know that Steven and Lauren are dating. Okay? I
do not know that Lauren and Steven are dating.
Okay. Okay. You haven't shown any proof, Fatty. I don't need
to. I know what the truth is. See you.
So, I go to Steven first.
Okay. He said that I asked Lauren out. I never asked Lauren out.
I went to Steven and I said, "Hey,
I know
that you dated Lauren in the past.
Lauren's a cool girl. Would you care if I asked her out?" And
he said, "No, I don't care. Go for it."
That's what he said to me.
I'm just talking to Lauren as a friend.
And I maybe it gets back to her from Steven like, "Hey, Connor's
thinking about asking you out or whatever."
And then Lauren says, "Oh, no. Um so so hey, Steven and I were
were thinking about seeing each other again." I don't know if
they ever physically saw each other again. I don't know if they
dated again. I have no idea what their actual relationship is.
I have no idea. But she said, "Hey, I'm talking to Steven again.
Um you know, I I want to see where that goes." I didn't ask her
out.
Okay? I didn't ask her out. She didn't ask me out. She didn't
say no.
I just never asked her out.
Were they back together this year? Maybe. I don't know.
They were at least talking.
They were at least talking as friends
and exploring the possibility of getting back together.
I hope they're still secretly dating. Me, too.
>> But I don't think that's the case.
So, what ended up happening was maybe a month ago,
maybe a few weeks ago,
they I I'll try to keep this as clean as I can without like leaking
too much details. But basically, I get word back
that Lauren wanted a commitment
And Steven was unable to commit.
I think that's very
I do believe this as well, right? It's it's pretty clear to me
that the reason Lauren was so quick to point that out
is because Destiny, again, super cool friend by the way, probably
messaged her immediately about it, yeah?
Like, why don't you just go
Why would Dude, if you're a real friend, don't you just go it
would actually make me uncomfortable if you I didn't even listen
to Destiny's response. I was sending a DM. But, why wouldn't
you just say that makes me uncomfortable actually? So, if you
wouldn't, that would be cool. Right? You don't want to tell them
that you're dating, but if you say that, it gets the same outcome
assuming Connor is willing to honor that given that he's asking
you in the first place anyway,
I think enough going to not hurt anybody.
Lauren wanted a commitment. Steven wouldn't commit. It's that
simple.
And so, this is where Steven lies.
This is where he lies to my face. He lies to your face.
He said, "Oh, Connor, number one, you don't have a wife." Okay,
I was married for 15 years. What's your longest relationship?
How long was Steven with Melina? Three?
I've dated people longer than Steven's been was with Melina.
So, okay, that's not very impressive to me. You
I was with one person for 15 years. That's an achievement to
me. Just because it didn't work out in the long term doesn't
mean that I'm not proud of what I did in reference to my
So, he goes, "Lol, you don't even have a wife anymore." Right?
How many wi- No, I say, "How many friends do you have left?"
And then he says, uh "I have more friends than you have wives."
Right?
That's what he said. Which by the way, the only thing Destiny
can say concretely about how many friends he has
more than zero. That's That's where he was willing to set the
bar. I'm pretty sure I got at least one.
>> So, that's funny. So, it's a good jab.
It's a good jab. But then he says,
uh Steven or I say, uh you know Lauren wanted to get back with
you. You know, um that she wants what's best for you, that she
cares about you, that she loves you, but you're such a
you can't you can't accept friendship, you can't let anybody
get close to you, you can't be a good partner, you can't do this,
you can't do that because you're such a animal.
And you can't take an L.
And so Steven says,
uh how about this L? Lauren and I have been secretly dating for
3 months. She didn't know that I knew that they were already
broken up. So, tell me I'm getting criticized
about being, you know, a a bad friend.
I feel like I'm calling out my friend on
and I'm telling him that he's a
By the way, this is like the only way they could think about
this, too. Like the idea that
somehow this only I I I do I truly believe this only works on
like the the most like deprived of human contact people in the
Like somehow and Dude, it's going to sound like I'm defending
myself here, but somehow there's like this super evil bad thing
if two people who originally talked to Destiny like start talking
or hooking up in some way. Like Destiny's tried to say basically
all of his old friends were hooking up with each other. It's
like, well, they have all the same interests and they're all
in the same community. That's probably just going to happen.
And somehow this has led to people backstabbing Destiny. I don't
even know how that could possibly be the case,
But it it only works on like the people who don't have like if
you've never been in that situation before where you meet somebody
at work or through college or wherever and you realize that oh
everybody who hangs out with each other, you know, a certain
number of hours a day, something eventually happens there or
there's something preventing it. Right? Like somebody's in a
monogamous relationship already. It's like super
Destiny hates Rally now just for dating Jasmine? I It would be
man, you'd have to be a uniquely like evil person to hate Ahrelevant
to be honest with you. Like the only people who would say they
hate Ahrelevant are snarkier types who don't like him, but they
have to say they hate him cuz they are too edgy and and hyperbolic,
right? That's the Those are the only people who could possibly
say they hate Ahrelevant. There's just nothing to hate about
him. Sorry.
And as if to prove my point, there's a bunch of people here.
There's a bunch of people in the chat getting ready to
Oh, also, I don't have any evidence that they dated at all, Kinkle
Ganesh. I don't have the I don't have any evidence for that.
So, I would have to somebody would have to show me evidence of
them dating. Do you know what I mean? Anyway.
yeah, anyway, they
>> Apparently, Connor couldn't possibly just be annoyed
with Destiny at doing some self-destructive behavior. It had
to be out of like jealousy over Lauren Southern. I don't know.
I don't know.
I it's just goofy to me. How should I take it that Steven, when
he's getting pressed
and he feels like he's in a corner,
he's willing to willfully lie
in order to make his opponent look worse
and in order to make himself look
How should I feel about my friend?
Because I'll tell you the way I feel about my friend. I feel
like I can't trust him. I can't trust him.
Going like like obviously he's lied to other people and I've
seen him get caught in his lies, but I've I've actually never
caught him in a lie.
Oh, that's that also gets rough when you like start to see how
obviously this guy lies to everybody, how he will like Destiny
I truly think you know when he he's talked about like cheating
and stuff and how it's like only bad if the other person finds
out. He truly believes deep in his heart of hearts that a lie
is not bad unless people catch you on it. Like it's totally normal.
He is a pathological liar. He will lie about everything always
until like it's pointed out and he can be held to it. That's
when it becomes something he has to talk about or care about,
right?
Like this is specifically the one I always think about the most
is when he's like three or four months after leaking the Pixie
tape that he's being sued for, right? Or one of the Pixie tapes
he's being sued for I should say.
he says in his chat during the Mr. Girl the end of the Mr. Girl
stuff, "I I have the cleanest DMs everywhere. I've never done
anything like wrong. You could check all of my DMs. I'd never
be caught. It's It's like um It's the same thing as the MethodJosh
thing, right? The whole like people don't really think I'm crazy
or people think I'm really crazy and then they sort of get normalized
and then eventually they realize I actually am that crazy.
Yeah. It's It's that.
I I have never caught Destiny in a lie. He said some crazy [__]
that I kind of gave him an eyebrow on.
He did not say that laugh my ass off. Yes, he did.
Yes, he did. He said, "You want to [__] L Lauren
and I have been secretly dating for the past three months." That's
what he said and he was wrong. He was lying.
>> have seen Steven be hyperbolic.
I've seen him try to destroy the public reputations of his enemies.
I've even arguably seen him caught in like a lie that could be
argued to be
you know, kind of like a fungible like like a like like a weird
you know, bending of the truth
but he's never lied to me.
He he's never said, "Hey Connor, here's something that I know
to be untrue
and I'm going to say it to you in order to obtain a benefit."
That's never happened. At le- at least not directly to me. I'm
sure it's happened to other people, but it's never happened.
It happens all the time, Connor. It literally happens all the
So, I'll just tell you right now I sir- I wish I knew this was
Connor's red line. If I'd known this was Connor's red line, I
could have provided him evidence of this stuff happening. Like,
oh, you just want to know that he's like basically lied to somebody
close to him and that it's provable like it's a provable lie
that he knew was a lie at the time? That's all you want?
Uh like I said, I want Steven to do
I want him to succeed in his career.
I want him to succeed in his personal
I want him to stabilize. >> check this timestamp. >> I
want him to be a fantastic
political commentator.
I want him to do beautiful analysis
of current events, news, and politics for him to become ingratiated
with the
uh the Yeah, unfortunately, he's kind of falling apart, man.
Like the all of the stuff he does on like in a political sense,
it's all very embarrassing and self-serving now. Like it it's
sort of just it seem seemingly all falling apart at this point
in my opinion. >> mainstream establishment and for him
to become a suc- wildly successful political commentator. That's
what I hope for Steven. And I hope that in his future relationships,
while he will probably still be promiscuous,
I hope that he is more careful not to hurt mentally ill
Okay, that's what I hope for Steven and I honestly believe that.
I am not even if we rekindled our friendship, I would never be
able to fully trust him.
I would never be able to fully trust him because in an opportunity
where he was getting pressed
with the truth
he decided to lie to my face
and to probably two to three thousand
in order to make me look bad and to make him look better by comparison.
So I will Destiny jacket again.
>> be able to fully trust him ever again.
So that's that. I mean we're probably not going to be friends.
Let's be real.
but even if we're not friends, that still makes me sad.
It still makes me sad that he lied right to my face.